From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Start from the top? I needed a driver. I couldn't drive. The problem was I wanted to have my same life, my same nice little suburban, get in the car and drive everywhere life.
从头说起吗？我需要一名司机。我没法开车。问题在于，我想要保持我原有的生活，那种舒适的郊区生活，那种随时上车就能去任何地方的生活。
Brigid was going blind in mid-life with a kid. She had stuff to do. So she took out an ad in the paper and hired somebody to drive her around, a guy named Harry. Nice guy. The first day, he picks her up in a van, takes her to her daughter's school at the end of the school day. They wait In line with the other parents.
布丽吉特在中年时失明，还有一个孩子。她有很多事情要处理。于是她在报纸上登了广告，雇了一个人开车接送她，那人叫哈里。是个好人。第一天，他开着一辆面包车来接她，在放学时间去接她女儿。他们和其他家长一起排队。
And Harry jumped out and started with his whisk broom. Opened up the van, opened up on both sides and whisk brooming and tidying it up.
哈里跳下车，拿着他的扫帚。打开面包车，两边车门都打开，开始扫地、整理。
On errands, Harry would park in the handicapped space. Or if that wasn't available, he'd park on the grass to save Brigid a few steps. She asked him to take her to the grocery store.
去办杂事时，哈里会把车停在残疾人车位。如果不方便，他就停在草地上，好让布丽吉特少走几步。她让他载她去杂货店。
Anyway, so then we get out and always he'd be wanting to help me up by the elbows. He wanted to help. And he says to me as we went into the grocery, here, let me get the basket for you. Let me carry your-- and I said, no, no no. I'm fine. And oh, he says, please. Oh, let me. I'm here to be of service for you. And he kind of shadowed me throughout the grocery store. And it was just very, again, a lot of that roar-roar fight back. And then this awful feeling of that he's just trying to help me. What I he really wanted was to help somebody out.
总之，我们下车时，他总是想扶着我的胳膊肘。他想帮忙。我们在走进杂货店时，他对我说：“来，我来帮你拿篮子。让我来帮你拿……”我说：“不，不，不用了。我很好。”但他接着说：“求你了，让我来吧。我就是来为您服务的。”他在杂货店里就像影子一样跟着我。这又是一种那种强烈抗拒的感觉。然后，我又产生了一种可怕的感觉——他只是想帮我。他真正想要的是帮助别人。
When you do something for somebody else, it always seems so simple. You just want to help. But in fact, you're forming a relationship with that person. And it's just as complicated as any relationship you can have. And like any other relationship, if you're not attentive to what the person actually wants, it's easy to blunder, which is why doing good for others is so difficult. In certain religions, the question of how to do good is a kind of obsession. Among my people, your Jews, it was traditionally a very big deal. In fact, one way to understand all Jewish law is as a set of instructions for doing good in the world. A set of instructions, I should say, so complicated, spanning so many centuries and thinkers, that in the 12th century, a philosopher named Maimonides actually made a crib sheet summarizing it all by listing the eight different ways that a person can do good for others.
当你为别人做某事时，这看起来总是很简单。你只是想帮忙。但事实上，你正在与那个人建立一段关系。它和你可能拥有的任何关系一样复杂。就像任何其他关系一样，如果你不注意对方真正想要什么，就很容易犯错，这就是为什么做好事如此困难。在某些宗教中，如何行善是一个痴迷的问题。在我的族人——你们的犹太人那里，这在传统上是一件大事。事实上，理解所有犹太法律的一种方式，就是将其视为一套在世界上行善的指导方针。我得说，这是一套非常复杂的指导方针，跨越了许多世纪和思想家，以至于在12世纪，一位名叫迈蒙尼德的哲学家实际上写了一份简要汇总，列出了一个人可以为他人行善的八种不同方式。
He listed in order of preference, from least desirable to the most. The lowest level of doing for others is giving grudgingly. Then there's giving less than you should but giving it cheerfully. Then giving after being asked. Then giving before being asked. And it continues on up through the most meritorious way to give, which is, tellingly, enabling the person you're helping to become self-sufficient so they don't need the help anymore.
他按偏好顺序列出了这些方式，从最不值得推荐的到最值得推荐的。行善的最低层次是勉强施舍。其次是施舍虽少但心态愉悦。再者是应求而予。然后是不请自予。它一直向上延伸，直到最高尚的行善方式，颇具深意的是，那便是让受助者变得自力更生，从而不再需要帮助。
Today on our program, stories of people trying to do good and why they often fail and why they occasionally succeed. Our program today in just two acts.
今天我们的节目，讲述的是人们尝试行善的故事，以及他们为何常常失败，又为何偶尔成功。我们今天的节目分为两幕。
Act One, You Can't Go Home Again, the story of two people trying to restore a small town to its former splendor and how the biggest obstacle turned out to be the people whose lives they wanted to improve.
第一幕，《你无法重回故里》，讲述了两人试图将一个小镇恢复到昔日辉煌，以及最大的阻碍竟是他们想要改善生活的人。
Act Two, Humanitarians. I chat with writer Philip Gourevitch about his encounters with international do-gooders, about Rwanda and Kosovo, about genocidal murders, and about Rick in Casablanca. Stay with us.
第二幕，《人道主义者》。我与作家菲利普·古雷维奇聊了聊他与国际行善者的相遇，关于卢旺达和科索沃，关于种族灭绝屠杀，以及关于《卡萨布兰卡》里的里克。请继续收听。
Act One. You Can't Go Home Again. You drive through cotton fields to get here, down old Highway 61 through Southeast Missouri. The nearest big town is Sikeston, population 18,000, 20 minutes away. When you drive into Canalou, Missouri, there's a sign that says, "population 319." And then just beyond it, another sign saying, "pavement ends." Then it's mostly gravel roads and trailer homes. The businesses on Main Street aren't just closed, they're gone, torn down decades ago. The movie theater, the restaurants, the grocery stores. People used to come here from all the surrounding towns. And when Kenny Wharton and his wife Jackie talk about what it was like in Canalou when they were kids, it's like they're describing a dream, a town in an old, black and white Hollywood film.
第一幕。《你无法重回故里》。你穿过棉田来到这里，沿着密苏里州东南部的61号老公路行驶。最近的大镇是塞克斯顿，人口1.8万，距离这里20分钟路程。当你开车进入密苏里州的卡纳卢时，有一个牌子写着“人口319”。再往前一点，另一个牌子写着“路面终点”。之后大多是碎石路和活动板房。主街上的商铺不仅关门了，它们早已消失，几十年前就被拆除了。电影院、餐厅、杂货店。以前人们会从周围所有的城镇来到这里。当肯尼·沃顿和他的妻子杰基谈论他们小时候的卡纳卢时，就像在描述一个梦，一个老式黑白好莱坞电影里的小镇。
This was the place on a Saturday. You had a hard time finding a place to park if you had a car. And we had everything in this little town. And people would come to town to visit. Old men would be playing Checkers up and down the streets. And the women would be visiting and kids would be playing. We played until 2:00 in the morning, we'd play.
这里曾是周六的好去处。如果你有车，很难找到停车位。在这个小镇，我们什么都有。人们会来到镇上做客。老人们会在街头巷尾下跳棋。女人们会串门，孩子们在玩耍。我们玩到凌晨2点，我们都会在那玩。
And us younger kids would be asleep in the back seat of the car because we would give out.
我们这些小孩会在车后座睡着，因为我们累坏了。
When I pulled into Canalou to talk to the Whartons, a four year old who lives next door to them, in a muddy shirt, mud on his face, no shoes in the cold, was playing in the drainage ditch. These ditches line both sides of every street in town because there's no sewage system here. Most people live in trailers not regular houses, and some people empty their septic tanks straight into the ditches where kids play.
当我开车进入卡纳卢去采访沃顿夫妇时，一个住在隔壁的四岁男孩，穿着泥泞的衬衫，脸上沾着泥，在寒冷的天气里没穿鞋，正在排水沟里玩耍。这些沟渠沿着镇上每条街道的两侧，因为这里没有污水处理系统。大多数人住在活动板房里，而不是正规房屋，有些人直接把化粪池排到孩子们玩耍的沟渠里。
The day I arrived, it had rained. The ground was soft, muddy everywhere. An adult who had let this four year old touch her face a few weeks back had gotten a rash on her face that even the doctors up in St. Louis couldn't identify or cure. This is the town that Kenny and Jackie couldn't wait to get back to.
我到达的那天下了雨。地面很软，到处都是泥。几周前让这个四岁男孩摸过脸的一位成年女性脸上长了皮疹，连圣路易斯的医生都无法确定或治愈。这就是肯尼和杰基迫不及待想要回来的小镇。
Anyway, this town was a good little town to grow up in. But we got married and we went away, went to the big  city of St. Louis. And we've been gone, I guess we were gone about 40 years.
总之，这个小镇是个成长的好地方。但我们结婚后就离开了，去了圣路易斯大城市。我们大概离开了有40年了。
And this has been a dream, to come back and build a home here.
能够回来并在这里安家，一直是我们的一个梦想。
In St. Louis, Kenny had been a supervisor at McDonnell Douglas. The Whartons lived in a house in the suburbs, raised two kids, active with neighborhood associations and the Board of Ed. And they thought, once they moved back to Canalou, they would try to bring back some of the spirit that they remembered growing up here in the '50s and '60s. Maybe start a little league, build a public park with swings and trees, put up a gym where kids could play ball, the kinds of straightforward, innocent improvements it's hard to imagine that anybody would oppose anywhere.
在圣路易斯，肯尼曾是麦克唐纳·道格拉斯公司的一名主管。沃顿夫妇住在一栋郊区房子里，抚养了两个孩子，积极参与社区协会和教育委员会的活动。他们心想，一旦搬回卡纳卢，他们就会试着带回一些他们在50年代和60年代成长时所记忆的那种精神。也许创办一个少年棒球队，建一个带秋千和树木的公共公园，建一个可以让孩子们打球的体育馆，这些都是那种简单、纯真且很难想象会有人反对的改善项目。
This is the story of why they failed, of why people did turn their backs on the Whartons, why three years of using every skill they have, devoting energy, devoting hope, only proved to them that Canalou did not want to be improved, and that something had changed in this small town that would take a lot more than two do-gooders to reverse.
这就是他们失败的故事，关于为什么人们背弃了沃顿夫妇，为什么三年来他们用尽了所有技能、投入精力、倾注希望，却只证明了卡纳卢并不想被改善，这个小镇发生了一些变化，仅凭两个行善者是无法扭转的。
I don't know if we can climb over the rubble, or we should walk around.
我不知道我们是该跨过这些瓦砾，还是绕道而行。
I can. I can. I know how.
我可以，我可以。我知道怎么走。
No, baby. You fall, see all this glass and this rock? Fall and hurt yourself.
不行，宝贝。你会摔倒的，看到这些玻璃和石头了吗？摔倒会伤到你的。
I didn't do that 'afore. I didn't do that. It's OK.
我以前没摔倒过。我没那样过。没事的。
Directly across the street from the Whartons is a trailer where Susan Drake lives with her five-year-old daughter Rachel, her eight-month-old son David, and her boyfriend Brad. Next to their trailer, one house down, is a lot that used to be an auto repair shop. The shop burned down 10 years ago, and nobody has cleaned up the site. It's a mess of broken glass, twisted, rusted out tin from the roof, concrete blocks from the walls, a stack of old tires. In short, an irresistible place for any small child, including Rachel and her friends. Susan and Brad and Rachel take me on a tour.
在沃顿夫妇街道对面，住着苏珊·德雷克和她五岁的女儿瑞秋、八个月大的儿子大卫以及她的男友布拉德。在他们拖车旁边，往下走一户，有一块曾经是汽车修理厂的空地。修理厂在10年前被烧毁，没人清理过现场。那里满是碎玻璃、从屋顶掉落扭曲生锈的铁皮、墙上的混凝土块，还有一堆旧轮胎。总之，这对任何小孩子来说都是一个无法抗拒的地方，包括瑞秋和她的朋友们。苏珊、布拉德和瑞秋带我参观了一圈。
You've got an open refrigerator standing here. Well, the door's standing wide open. There. Right there.
这里立着一台敞开的冰箱。你看，门大敞着。就在那儿。
You can't get in here.
你进不去那里。
Well, the shelves are in there. But if you really wanted in there, you could get in there. But that's dangerous baby. When you get inside there and that door shuts, you can't open it from the inside. You're stuck in there and you could die, suffocate.
嗯，架子在里面。但如果你真的想进去，你还是进得去。但这很危险，宝贝。当你进去之后门关上，你从里面是打不开的。你会困在里面，可能会窒息死掉。
Rachael considers a diplomatic response.
瑞秋正在思考一个外交辞令般的回答。
Well, we went in the cars, though. We went in the cars. Not here. We didn't went here. We got in the cars.
可是我们钻进过车里。我们钻进过车里。不是在这里。我们没钻进这里。我们钻的是车。
The cars where Rachel likes to play are just a few feet back from the building, nearly two dozen old Impalas and Malibus and Chevys sitting in a yard, no fence, lots of rust, broken glass. Brad chooses this day, the day with visitors watching, to do some child proofing-- knock the refrigerator face down so no kid can climb in, push over a dangerously crumbling wall, shove a car to the ground that looks like it's about to fall over on any kid who leans on it.
瑞秋喜欢玩耍的那些车就在建筑后面几英尺远的地方，近两打旧英帕拉、马里布和雪佛兰车停在院子里，没有围栏，满是铁锈和碎玻璃。布拉德选择今天，在有游客围观的情况下，做了一些防护——把冰箱放倒以免小孩爬进去，推倒了一面危险的摇摇欲坠的墙，把一辆看起来随时会倒在倚靠它的孩子身上的车推到地上。
Rachael, meanwhile, tells her mom about the new swing the kids are all using. It is a dead power line that hangs from the top of a telephone pole behind the abandoned school. As the kids swing, the pole quietly wobbles back and forth. We walk through the rubble. And it turns out that this lot, which will be cleaned up in most places-- not necessarily out of civic pride but at least out of fear that somebody would get hurt and sue the owner or the city-- this property belongs to Susan's cousin, little Jim. And Susan and Brad say that all the town has to do is threaten him with a ticket or a citation or a fine.
与此同时，瑞秋告诉她妈妈孩子们都在用的新秋千。那是一根从废弃学校后面电线杆顶端垂下来的死电线。当孩子们荡秋千时，电线杆会静静地来回摇晃。我们穿过废墟。原来这块地，在大多数地方本该被清理干净——不一定是因为公民自豪感，至少是因为担心有人受伤并起诉业主或城市——但这块地属于苏珊的表弟，小吉姆。苏珊和布拉德说，镇上只要威胁他开罚单、传票或者罚款就行了。
He would clean it up.
他就会清理的。
Right. Yeah, he would.
对。没错，他会。
The fact of the matter is--
事实是——
But he's never been pressured.
但他从来没被施加压力过。
--who's going to spend money they don't have to spend? Who's going to spend money they don't have to spend? And nobody's told him to spend any money.
——谁会去花他们根本没有的钱？谁会去花他们根本没有的钱？而且没人叫他花钱。
Basically why he's not cleaned it up. Nobody's pressured him to clean it up.
这基本上就是他没清理的原因。没人强迫他清理。
Sweep it up.
扫干净。
It's just ridiculous is what it is.
这简直太荒谬了。
Laziness, yeah.
懒惰，没错。
Canalou's a hole in the wall. That's all it is. It's a mud hole that they ought to bulldoze.
卡纳卢就是个坑。仅此而已。那是个他们早该用推土机推平的泥坑。
There's nothing here.
这里什么都没有。
There's no store. There's no bank. There's nothing for kids to do. There's one soda machine in town, and it's in a guy's driveway.
没有商店。没有银行。孩子们没地方可去。镇上只有一台自动售货机，而且是在一个人的车道上。
When we lived here, the rules were strictly enforced. You kept your place maintained. If a car was broke down on the streets, you had 24 hours to get it fixed. It didn't sit there.
我们住在这里时，规则执行得很严。你必须维护好你的地盘。如果有车在街上坏了，你有24小时把它修好。它不能一直停在那儿。
That's Jackie Wharton again. She and Kenny moved back to Canalou in October of 1995. And it wasn't long before Jackie started a ladies auxiliary to begin with some little community projects. It was three ladies at first. It got to over a dozen. To raise money, they sold stuff at flea markets, delivered hearts and flowers on Valentine's Day, threw fundraiser dinners. And after a few months, they had earned $2,000 in profits, enough to start a softball league, throw a neighborhood party. And at this point, the saga of good intentions gone wrong began.
那又是杰基·沃顿。她和肯尼在1995年10月搬回卡纳卢。没过多久，杰基就成立了一个妇女辅助会，开始做一些小型的社区项目。起初只有三位女士。后来增加到了十几个人。为了筹款，她们在跳蚤市场卖东西，在情人节派送心形礼物和鲜花，举办筹款晚宴。几个月后，她们赚了2000美元的利润，足够办一个垒球联盟，举办一场邻里聚会。就在这时，好意办坏事的传奇开始了。
We started several projects and boy, we just met opposition at every corner because they just couldn't understand why. The ladies auxiliary gave out free Christmas baskets to every home in town. We had fruit and candy and cookies, homemade cookies in them. We gave out 133 baskets. We did not get one thank you call. But we got five negative calls, and we considered it a success because that's all we got.
我们发起了几个项目，天哪，我们处处碰壁，因为他们根本无法理解为什么。妇女辅助会给镇上的每一户人家免费发放了圣诞篮。里面有水果、糖果和饼干，自制的饼干。我们一共发了133个篮子。我们没收到一个感谢电话。但我们接到了五个负面电话，我们认为这是成功，因为我们只接到了这些。
They were angry, some people, because we left the baskets hanging on their door. And some didn't like us knocking on the doors after dark. And oh, we got one lady's dogs upset and she didn't like that because her dogs got upset.
有些人很生气，因为我们把篮子挂在他们门上。有些人不喜欢我们在天黑后敲门。哦，还有一个女士的狗被惊到了，她不喜欢，因为她的狗被惊到了。
What did you say to them?
你跟他们说什么了？
I said, well, we're sorry. We apologize. What can you say? We're sorry. We're sorry it wasn't good enough. We're sorry your dogs were upset. We're sorry. No ma'am, we won't leave anything hanging on your door again. And what can you say? You handle it.
我说，嗯，我们很抱歉。我们道歉。你能说什么呢？我们很抱歉。抱歉不够好。抱歉惊到了你的狗。抱歉。不，女士，我们以后不会再把东西挂在你的门上了。你能说什么呢？你只能应付过去。
Meanwhile, Kenny tried to get a grant to blacktop the streets, started things in motion to get a sewer system finally constructed. He tried to get junk cleared off yards. He talked to his neighbors about bringing a restaurant or a grocery store back to Main Street, maybe get the hat factory down in Oran to set up some of their subcontracting work out of Canalou, generate some jobs. And before long, this 65-year-old retiree, who looks a lot like a youthful Lyndon Johnson, found himself running for mayor.
与此同时，肯尼试图申请拨款来铺设柏油路，着手启动建设污水处理系统的程序。他试图让人清理院子里的垃圾。他跟邻居们商量把餐厅或杂货店带回主街，或许让奥兰的制帽厂把一些分包工作放在卡纳卢，创造一些就业机会。没过多久，这位65岁的退休人员，长得像年轻时的林登·约翰逊，发现自己正在竞选市长。
I just told him I was interested in cleaning up the town and making it nice. And everybody that I talked to said, well, I'm not registered to vote. But I'm sure going to vote for you. We sure need that. And I got them over to register to vote, and they voted for the other guy. Sure did.
我只是告诉他们我很有兴趣清理这个小镇，让它变得美好。我和每个人交谈时，他们都说，嗯，我没有登记投票。但我一定会投给你。我们确实需要这个。结果我帮他们去登记投票，他们却投给了另一个人。真的投给了别人。
This is true.
这是真的。
To understand why Kenny lost, I visited Charles and Kay Southard. Like Kenny, they grew up in a sharecropper's family. Charles' people were farmers and laborers. Like most of the older people in town, he picked cotton as a kid.
为了了解肯尼为什么会输，我拜访了查尔斯和凯·绍萨德。像肯尼一样，他们是在佃农家庭长大的。查尔斯的家人是农民和劳工。像镇上大多数老年人一样，他小时候摘过棉花。
The hand-picking stopped about 15 years ago, and they all went to machines. And that's where the world messed up, by going to the machines.
人工采摘大约15年前就停止了，他们全都改用机器了。世界就是在那时候变糟的，因为改用了机器。
Then a bunch of Mexicans came down here and took everybody's job working.
然后一群墨西哥人来到这里，抢走了所有人的工作。
Yeah, there's a bunch of them immigrants in here. What they ought to do is just pack them up and send them back to Mexico where they belong. That way, American citizens will have more jobs instead of giving it to them.
没错，这里有一群移民。他们该做的就是把这些人打包送回墨西哥，回他们该去的地方。这样美国公民就有更多工作，而不是把工作给他们。
The Southards run a live bait business from their house, a double-wide trailer with additions built on. In the living room is a big tank with over-sized goldfish in it, which they sell as pets and as bait. It's Charles Southard's driveway that has the town's one soda machine, but there's lots of other junk in the yard too, an old wagon, broken tables, cans, bottles, and a wide assortment of nondescript rusted out pieces of machinery. There are lots of yards like this around town. I sat in the kitchen with Charles and Kay and asked what people thought of Kenny, why he lost the election.
绍萨德夫妇在家经营着一家活饵生意，住在一个加盖了扩建部分的双宽活动板房里。客厅里有一个大鱼缸，里面养着巨大的金鱼，他们把这些鱼当作宠物和鱼饵出售。查尔斯·绍萨德的车道上有镇上唯一的一台自动售货机，但院子里还有很多其他垃圾，一辆旧马车、破桌子、罐头、瓶子，以及各种各样难以名状的生锈机械碎片。镇上有很多这样的院子。我和查尔斯、凯坐在厨房里，询问人们对肯尼的看法，以及他为什么会输掉选举。
You want the truth or you want a lie?
你是要听真话还是要听假话？
I want the truth.
我要听真话。
Because he was going around trying to run this town, telling everybody how to do things and how it was going to be done. He was saying, you're going to keep your yard clean, you weren't going to have no toys, you weren't going to have no garbage, no trash, and no junk cars in this-- if he's going to do that, he better go back to where he come from, from down around Memphis. Because you don't come into a little town like that and try to take over and run everything. Because this town's been this way ever since it was built. And one guy ain't going to change it. That's the reason he made so many enemies and couldn't get elected. If he would have just played it smart and went along with everybody, then after he got elected tried to do his thing, he might have won it.
因为他到处试图掌控这个小镇，告诉每个人怎么做事，事情该怎么做。他说，你得保持院子整洁，不准有玩具，不准有垃圾，不准有废旧车辆——如果他要这么做，他最好滚回他原来的地方，从孟菲斯附近来回哪去。因为你不能来到这样一个小镇，试图接管一切，掌控一切。因为这个小镇建成以来就是这个样子。一个人是改变不了它的。这就是他招致那么多敌意，无法当选的原因。如果他当时聪明点，顺应大家，当选后再尝试做他的事，他或许就能赢了。
In a sense, Kenny made exactly the kind of political error that professional politicians always try to avoid. He told voters that they were going to have to make changes themselves. They were going to have to sacrifice. They were going to have to get off their butts if change was going to come. What made this especially hard to listen to was the fact that Kenny made a lot more money, even retired, than most people in town. Many Canalou families get food stamps or SSI.
在某种意义上，肯尼犯了专业政客总是试图避免的那种政治错误。他告诉选民，他们必须自己做出改变。他们必须做出牺牲。如果改变真的要到来，他们就必须从自己的懒散中走出来。让这话尤其刺耳的是，肯尼即使退休，赚的钱也比镇上大多数人多得多。许多卡纳卢家庭依靠食品券或社会安全补助（SSI）度日。
Besides Kenny's retirement checks, Jackie had won $286,644.54 on a quarter slot machine back in 1984. Jackie and Kenny were the talk of the town for a while when they actually built a garage for their cars with an electric garage door opener, the first and only one in Canalou. These were the people who were going around telling people what to do? City people with their city ideas? Yankees, really? No wonder so many people did not believe that Kenny was even from Canalou.
除了肯尼的退休金支票，杰基在1984年还在一台25美分的角子机上赢了286,644.54美元。杰基和肯尼曾有一段时间是镇上的谈资，当时他们为车盖了一个车库，还装了电动车库门开启器，这是卡纳卢唯一的一个。就是这些人到处告诉别人该怎么做？带着城市理念的城市人？其实就是北方佬？难怪很多人甚至不相信肯尼真的是从卡纳卢出来的。
Add to that the rumors that floated through town, that Kenny was going to make it illegal to own more than two cars, that Kenny was going to force people to give up older model trailers, or trailers on Main Street, or trailers completely, that Kenny made a man get rid of a goat that he kept in his yard. Rumors that were all untrue.
再加上镇上流传的谣言，说肯尼要让拥有超过两辆车变成非法，肯尼要强迫人们放弃旧款拖车，或者主街上的拖车，或者完全禁止拖车，肯尼让人处理掉了一只他养在院子里的山羊。这些谣言全都是假的。
I know he came up here and told me my yard is junky. He said, well, you've got to clean this stuff up. Says, you don't, we're going to give you a ticket and you're going to pay a fine. Like you, if you were out here in these old tires, and I know you've seen them, that people plant flowers in. Well, he had enough galls to come up here and tell me, I've got four of them out there, that I had to get rid of them.
我知道他来到这儿，告诉我我的院子乱七八糟。他说，嗯，你得把这些东西清理掉。说如果不清理，我们要给你开罚单，还要交罚款。就像你，如果你在这里看到那些旧轮胎，我知道你见过它们，人们在里面种花。好吧，他居然有胆量来到这儿告诉我——我外面有四个那种轮胎——我必须把它们处理掉。
I told him, naw, man, that's my flower pots. I don't get rid of them. Well, you got to. Says, that's pollution. Says, that's cluttering up the ground. I says, I don't care. It's my ground, my property, if I want to clutter it up, I clutter it up. You just stay outside the fence here. You need to just shut up and leave them alone.
我告诉他，不，伙计，那是我的花盆。我才不处理掉。他说，你必须处理掉。说是污染。说是把地面弄得很乱。我说，我才不管。这是我的地，我的财产，如果我想把它弄乱，我就弄乱。你最好待在这栅栏外面。你还是闭嘴，别管闲事。
In a place like Canalou, where people have so little, they're naturally kind of protective about the little they have. In talking to Charles Southard, it's hard not to wonder if Kenny couldn't have just presented his ideas differently and won more people over. Because if you ask Charles and Kay what changes they'd like to see in Canalou, their list actually matches a lot of the things on Kenny's list.
在卡纳卢这样的地方，人们拥有的东西很少，所以他们天生对自己仅有的一点东西有保护欲。在与查尔斯·绍萨德交谈时，很难不怀疑肯尼是否可以换种方式提出他的想法，从而赢得更多人的支持。因为如果你问查尔斯和凯他们想在卡纳卢看到什么改变，他们的清单其实和肯尼清单上的许多内容不谋而合。
They need somebody to keep these roads in shape. They need a trash truck to pick the trash up.
他们需要有人把这些道路维护好。他们需要垃圾车来把垃圾运走。
They need to put a grocery store in here.
他们需要在这里开一家杂货店。
Put a what?
开什么？
A grocery store. And a game room for these kids.
一家杂货店。还有一个给这些孩子玩的游乐室。
A typical mayoral election in Canalou, I was told, brings out 50, maybe 60 voters. This one turned into a referendum on Kenny Wharton. And people felt so strongly that nearly 200 voted. Kenny got 89 votes. His opponent, the current mayor, Charles Joyce, 98. Kenny lost by nine votes.
有人告诉我，卡纳卢典型的市长选举通常有50，也许60名选民出来投票。这次选举变成了针对肯尼·沃顿的全民公投。人们态度非常强烈，有近200人参与了投票。肯尼获得了89票。他的对手，现任市长查尔斯·乔伊斯获得了98票。肯尼以9票之差落败。
Rick Foraker is an outsider who spent a lot of time in Canalou the last 11 years, ever since he started dating his wife, Lavanna, who grew up here, who likes it here. Rick's job is a strange one. He works for companies that do disaster relief. He's kind of a mercenary do-gooder, a professional humanitarian. Though he just calls himself a vulture. He flies to places where there have been floods or hurricanes, works five, six months, seven days a week, 12 hours a day, makes a lot of money, and comes home, spends months doing nothing.
里克·福拉克是一个外来者，在过去11年里在卡纳卢待了很多时间，自从他开始和他的妻子拉瓦娜约会以来，她在这里长大，喜欢这里。里克的工作很奇怪。他为处理灾难救援的公司工作。他算是某种雇佣兵类型的行善者，职业人道主义者。虽然他只称自己为秃鹰。他飞往发生洪水或飓风的地方，工作五六个月，每周七天，每天12小时，赚很多钱，然后回家，花几个月时间无所事事。
Every November and September, you can find my butt glued to the TV set, to the Weather Channel watching for the hurricanes.
每年11月和9月，你都能发现我整个人黏在电视机前，盯着天气频道观测飓风。
I didn't know that such a job existed.
我以前都不知道还有这种工作。
Very few people do. That's why it pays good.
没几个人知道。这就是为什么薪水高。
As an outsider to this town who's observed Canalou for a decade, Rick has an entire theory of how the town works and why Kenny and Jackie would do so badly here.
作为一个观察了卡纳卢十年的外来者，里克有一整套关于这个城镇如何运作，以及为什么肯尼和杰基在这里会表现得如此糟糕的理论。
Downtown, this town used to thrive and party more than Sikeston, up until the mid-'60s. And it's like everything else. It was a railroad town. The railroad closed down, so the cotton mills closed down. So the cotton mills closed down, no jobs. People left with the jobs. Businesses didn't have any more money. People weren't spending money in businesses so the businesses closed. And voila, you have a ghost town. It's just a typical ghost town story.
镇中心，直到60年代中期，这个镇以前比塞克斯顿还要兴旺、还要热闹。这就像其他地方一样。这是个铁路小镇。铁路停运了，棉纺厂也就倒闭了。棉纺厂倒闭了，没工作了。人们跟着工作离开了。企业没钱了。人们不再在企业里消费，于是企业就关门了。于是，瞧，你得到了一座鬼城。这只是一个典型的鬼城故事。
And now what you've got left here are the die hards, the people that just won't move out because they're afraid to go anywhere else, they can't afford to go anywhere else. And they keep them at a poverty level. People down here, they don't make any money. That's my main bitch about being here. The jobs that they've got down here for $6 and $7 an hour are jobs I'm used to making $12, $15 at home.
现在剩下的是那些死守在这里的人，那些因为害怕去其他地方、或者负担不起去其他地方的费用而坚持不走的人。他们让他们维持在贫困水平。这里的人，他们赚不到钱。这是我在这里最主要的不满。他们在那里赚每小时6、7美元的工作，是我在家乡习惯赚每小时12、15美元的工作。
What kind of jobs are you talking about?
你说的是哪种工作？
Well, it's just like driving the tan dump truck. I go home, I make $14, $15, I've made as high as $17 an hour.
嗯，就比如开这种棕色自卸卡车。我回家能赚14、15美元，我最高时薪达到过17美元。
This is back home in Springfield, Illinois.
这是在伊利诺伊州斯普林菲尔德的家乡。
Yeah. Springfield, Illinois. Down here, it's $7 an hour, and they expect you to be on call seven days a week, 24 hours a day. They don't want to pay up any kind of an overtime situation. An when they hand you this paycheck, they've just got this attitude like they own you. They're doing you a large favor. I've personally got some really bad news for them. It's no favor.
没错，伊利诺伊州斯普林菲尔德。在这儿，每小时7美元，而且他们希望你随时待命，一周七天，一天24小时。他们不想支付任何形式的加班费。当你拿到这张工资支票时，他们那种态度就像他们拥有你一样。他们觉得他们是在给你天大的恩惠。我个人得给他们传达一个坏消息。这算不上什么恩惠。
Most of these people who are in this town have been in this town. So they figure they're here, what they got's what they're going to get, they just get depressed and upset and aggravated and look around, the hell with it.
镇上大多数人一直待在这个镇子里。所以他们觉得既然在这儿，现在得到的就是他们能得到的全部了，他们就变得沮丧、心烦、恼火，四处看看，管它呢。
And so people don't try to fix things, Rick says, or make their lives better. People have given up. And they stay because it's cheap. Rick's property taxes are $27 a year. Picture then, into this setting come Kenny and Jackie Wharton, like people from another America, an America of people on the go, of self-help seminars, of motivational speakers. Jackie used to be a motivational speaker.
所以人们不去尝试解决问题，里克说，或者改善他们的生活。人们已经放弃了。他们留下来是因为这里便宜。里克的房产税是一年27美元。那么，设想一下，肯尼和杰基·沃顿进入这样的环境，就像来自另一个美国的人，一个充满活力、自助研讨会、励志演说家的美国。杰基曾是一名励志演说家。
Jackie and Kenny arrive in Canalou and it was like a collision of two different visions of what it means to live in this country. Is Canalou a small town where people have pride and self-reliance, where neighbors band together to build civic institutions? Or is Canalou a place full of people who simply cannot get it together to improve their lives?
杰基和肯尼来到卡纳卢，这就像两种关于在这个国家生活意味着什么的截然不同的愿景发生了碰撞。卡纳卢是一个人们拥有自豪感和自力更生精神、邻里团结起来建设公民机构的小镇吗？还是说，卡纳卢是一个住满无法齐心协力改善自己生活的人的地方？
I'd like to say, once again, the sewer system. God, it'd be so nice to be able to go out in the yards in the summertime and not smell somebody's septic tank. Or look out across somebody's yard after rain and not see black water running to the ditches. But they're so scared. Well, I guess it's because they don't have the money. They're so scared that this is going to cost them everything they've got that they don't want nothing to do with it.
我想再说一遍，关于污水处理系统。天哪，如果在夏天能出门去院子里闻不到别人化粪池的味道该多好。或者下雨后看向别人的院子，看不到黑水流向沟渠该多好。但他们太害怕了。嗯，我想是因为他们没钱。他们太害怕这将耗尽他们所有的一切，所以他们什么都不想做。
And so it came to pass that in this town where people do not want to clean their yards, where nobody wants to be bothered, the democratic process worked pretty much as well as you could imagine. The mayor they chose instead of Kenny is, in a certain sense, the perfect representative of people.
于是便出现了这样的情况：在这个人们不想打扫院子、没人想被麻烦的镇上，民主程序运作得和你想象的一样好。他们选出的替代肯尼的市长，在某种意义上，是人们的完美代表。
One of the biggest and junkiest people in town is the mayor.
镇上最邋遢、最有垃圾的人之一就是市长。
Describe what his house is like.
描述一下他家是什么样子的。
Well, I really can't. I could kind of show it to you.
嗯，我真的不能描述。我可以带你看看。
We walk to Rick's back window.
我们走到里克的后窗。
Well, you can get kind of a view. The two houses right straight through, those two houses there, all that pipe and stuff sitting over there on the ground, that's his.
嗯，你可以看个大概。正对着的那两栋房子，那两栋房子那里，地上放着的所有那些管道之类的东西，那是他的。
You say pipes, each one longer than a car.
你说管道，每一根都比车还长。
Twenty foot. That's irrigation pipe.
20英尺长。那是灌溉管道。
That's his yard?
那是他的院子？
Yeah, that's part of it. That's one lot. He's got two big lots there. That's where he keeps all of his junk. He's got all kinds of junk farm equipment, trucks, tractor trailers, semis and stuff in the yard.
没错，那是他院子的一部分。那是地块之一。他有两块大空地在那儿。那就是他堆放所有垃圾的地方。他院子里有各种各样的废旧农用设备、卡车、牵引式拖车、大型半挂车之类的东西。
I've been mayor for a long time. People pretty well know what's going to happen.
我当市长已经很久了。人们很清楚会发生什么。
Charles Joyce is such a successful politician that he does not actually remember how many times he's been reelected since the early 1980s. When I visit, it's just before dinner. He's a farmer in his 60s, sat on a couch in his smallish living room, TV playing, one of those little TV tray tables next to him with some iced tea on it. I've been warned by the gossip line in Canalou that Mr. Joyce had somehow absconded the beautiful cypress floors of the old gymnasium that was torn down and used them for his own living room. This was nowhere near true. If anything, Canalou was a town too poor even to steal from. Mr. Joyce says there's no money to pay for a full-time policeman, for a judge, for a prosecutor. In short, there is no money to enforce any ordinances of any kind that they might have.
查尔斯·乔伊斯是一位非常成功的政客，他甚至记不清自80年代初以来自己连任了多少次。我去拜访时，正好是晚饭前。他是一位60多岁的农民，坐在他那间略小的客厅沙发上，电视开着，旁边放着一个小托盘桌，上面有些冰茶。卡纳卢的流言蜚语线曾警告我，乔伊斯先生不知怎么偷走了被拆除的旧体育馆的精美柏木地板，用来装修他自己的客厅。这根本不是真的。如果有的话，卡纳卢是一个甚至连偷窃都贫瘠的城镇。乔伊斯先生说没有钱支付全职警察、法官或检察官的工资。简而言之，没有钱来执行他们可能拥有的任何性质的条例。
I'm telling you, property taxes is nothing. That's what I've been telling you. See, we've got lots that bring in $0.50 and stamps is $0.35, right?
我告诉你，房产税根本不算什么。我一直在告诉你。你看，我们有很多地块带来的收入只有50美分，邮票就要35美分，对吧？
So you're saying, basically, your hands are tied.
所以你是说，基本上，你的手脚被束缚住了。
Well, do you know what the mayor can do in a 4 Class city?
嗯，你知道市长在四级城市能做什么吗？
I don't. What?
我不知道。做什么？
Well, he can't do very much.
嗯，他做不了什么。
Total budget of the Canalou general fund, $10,000 to $12,000. People don't want to pay more in taxes, Mayor Joyce told me, so that limits services. I ask him about the hazardous junk that any child could get hurt on and sue the city. He said that it would take money to enforce the law or money to clean it up. That is money they do not have for a cleanup that people do not want.
卡纳卢一般基金的总预算为1万到1.2万美元。乔伊斯市长告诉我，人们不想多交税，所以这限制了服务。我问他关于任何孩子都可能受伤并起诉城市的危险垃圾。他说，执法或清理需要钱。而他们根本没有钱去清理那些人们本身就不想清理的东西。
See, what's junk to me may be your treasure. There's a couple over here that I understood was told that they had to get rid of a bus that they had in their backyard. That's the only storage building they've got. But that bus has got a good coat of paint on it. It's jacked up. It's on blocks. And they're not really bothering me. They're on his property. See, we're not Sikeston. We ain't never been, we'll never be.
你看，对我来说是垃圾的东西可能是你的宝贝。我听说这边有一对夫妇被告知他们必须处理掉后院里的一辆公共汽车。那是他们唯一的储物间。但那辆公共汽车涂了一层很好的漆。它被千斤顶顶起来了。它放在砖块上。他们并没有真的打扰我。它们是在他的财产上。看，我们不是塞克斯顿。我们从来都不是，也永远不会是。
And this is one of the few things, privileges we've got, that we don't have a bunch of young storm troopers running around here saying, we're going to write you a ticket. I've got a [UNINTELLIGIBLE] here. They were going to write him a ticket because his kids had broke toys. That was the only toys that they had.
这是我们拥有的为数不多的特权之一，就是我们没有一群年轻的冲锋队在到处转悠说，我们要给你开罚单。我这里有一个[听不清]。他们要给他开罚单，因为他的孩子有损坏的玩具。那可是孩子们仅有的玩具。
Broken toys just sitting out in the yard, you mean?
你是说损坏的玩具放在院子里？
Yeah. They were out in the yard, because that's where they played with him, was in the yard. Well, the toys were broke. But those were the best toys the kids had. If we had to get rid of them, then they would have no toys at all. I don't agree. I don't agree. And I've been elected mayor a bunch of times.
是的。它们放在院子里，因为他们就是在院子里玩它们的。嗯，玩具是坏了。但那是孩子们最好的玩具。如果我们必须把它们处理掉，那他们就什么玩具都没有了。我不同意。我不同意。我已经多次当选市长了。
A lot of people do like it here. One night I stopped by Rick's when his wife Lavanna and their 13-year-old nephew Jason were there. My producer Julie Snyder was there, and Mary Wilternburg, who knew her way around Canalou and was helping with this story. We all talked for a long time. It was fun.
很多人确实喜欢这里。一天晚上我顺道去了里克家，他的妻子拉瓦娜和他们13岁的侄子杰森也在那。我的制片人朱莉·斯奈德也在那里，还有熟悉卡纳卢情况并协助这个故事的玛丽·威尔滕堡。我们大家聊了很久。很有意思。
I might be able to call my mom and I can stay till 9:30. Can I call?
我或许能给我妈打电话，我可以留到9点半。我可以打吗？
Call.
打吧。
OK, because--
好的，因为——
Jason did his impressions for us and then gave us permission to broadcast them, a fact which will surely horrify him three or four years from now when he's in high school. He did Ace Ventura.
杰森为我们表演了他的模仿秀，并允许我们播出，等他三四年后上高中时，这件事肯定会让他感到震惊。他模仿了王牌大贱谍。
Hi there, nice to see you. Bumblebee Tuna.
嘿，很高兴见到你。大黄蜂金枪鱼。
The guy from Sling Blade .
来自《弹簧刀》的家伙。
Well, I was sitting out in my garage one day, mm-hmm. I heard my mama screaming, and so I walked out there and I saw that Kaiser blade. I call it a sling blade. So I picked it up, mm-hmm.
嗯，有一天我坐在我的车库里，嗯哼。我听到我妈妈在尖叫，所以我走出去，看到了那把凯撒刀。我叫它弹簧刀。所以我捡起它，嗯哼。
Forrest Gump.
阿甘正传。
I'm a little rusty on this, but I'm OK. Hi. My name's Forrest, Forrest Gump. People call me Forrest Gump. That-that-that's all I got to say about that.
在这方面我有点生疏，但我还可以。嗨。我的名字叫阿甘，阿甘。人们叫我阿甘。这——这——这就是关于那件事我想说的全部。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Rick teased Lavanna about Canalou, the town that she made him move to. People here are fighting modernization, he says. She just laughs at him.
里克调侃拉瓦娜关于卡纳卢的事，这个她让他搬来的小镇。他说，这里的人正在对抗现代化。她只是对他大笑。
Oh, they are not. Get off of that.
哦，他们才没有。别这样说。
Then I ask her the question that Rick says he's been asking for eight years, since they got married. Why does she want to stay in Canalou?
然后我问了她那个里克说他八年来一直在问的问题，自从他们结婚以来。为什么她想留在卡纳卢？
I knew you were going to ask me that. You know, honest to god, I don't know why. There's no reason to live here except for if you've got friends or relatives. Well, it's like when I lived across the street, that big porch out there. Every morning I just loved that porch. I'd go outside and drink my coffee. And I'd dream about when I grow old sitting on the porch with my buddy-- my buddy lives across the street-- just sitting on my porch just swinging and gossiping about this one and gossiping about that one. Not mean, nasty things, just boring old, oh, did you see what she did to her hair? You know, just [BLEEP] like that. I don't know, that'd probably just bore the socks off y'all. But to me, that's just one of my dreams, is just to sit and grow old with my friends.
我就知道你会问我这个。你知道，说实话，我不知道为什么。没理由住在这里，除非你有朋友或亲戚。嗯，就像我以前住对面的时候，那个大门廊。每天早上我都喜欢那个门廊。我会走到外面喝咖啡。我会梦想着当我变老时，和我的朋友——我的朋友住在对面——坐在这个门廊上，只是坐着晃悠，八卦这个，八卦那个。不是那种恶毒、讨厌的事情，只是无聊的老调重弹，哦，你看见她把头发弄成那样了吗？你知道，就是那种[哔]话。我不知道，那对你们来说可能听起来无聊透顶。但对我来说，这就是我的梦想之一，只是和我的朋友们坐着一起变老。
In her various projects to improve Canalou, Jackie had her successes and her failures. The big successes mostly came in this last year, her third year in town. The ladies auxiliary through a big 4th of July cookout that actually drew a crowd with booths and games, a petting zoo for the little kids, a fireworks display that everybody said was even better than Sikeston's, a Country/Western band for the adults. Some people even danced. The only problem was most of the crowd was from the surrounding towns, perhaps only a third from Canalou.
在改善卡纳卢的各种项目中，杰基有成功也有失败。大的成功主要来自这最后一年，她在镇上的第三年。妇女辅助会举办了一场大型的7月4日烧烤活动，确实吸引了很多人，有摊位和游戏，给小孩子们准备的宠物动物园，每个人都说比塞克斯顿还要精彩的烟花表演，为成年人准备的乡村/西部乐队。有些人甚至跳了舞。唯一的问题是大多数人群来自周围城镇，可能只有三分之一来自卡纳卢。
That finally changed last Halloween. The ladies auxiliary held a costume contest with a weenie roast and a big bonfire. Finally, they drew 50 or 60 people from within Canalou, people of all ages.
这种情况在去年万圣节终于改变了。妇女辅助会举办了一场化妆比赛，还有烤热狗和一场大型篝火晚会。最终，她们吸引了50到60位卡纳卢本地人，各个年龄段的人都来了。
That, to me, was the most heartwarming experience I've done here. It was a whole different group of people that came out. There's something about a bonfire.
对我来说，那是我在这里做过的最令人暖心的经历。来了一群完全不同的人。篝火总有一种魔力。
After that party, Jackie finally felt comfortable enough in town to start going to church in Canalou. Every now and then, people started telling her they appreciated what the ladies auxiliary was doing in town. This is also during the period that Kenny was running for mayor, going door to door. And talking face to face, most people were encouraging. He thought he was a shoe-in.
在那场聚会之后，杰基终于感到在镇上自在了一些，开始去卡纳卢的教堂。时不时地，人们开始告诉她，他们很欣赏妇女辅助会在镇上所做的一切。这段时间也是肯尼竞选市长、挨家挨户走访的时期。面对面交谈时，大多数人都表示鼓励。他以为自己胜券在握。
I was feeling elated. I was feeling like, oh boy, everything is going to work. We're going to be-- the community is coming together.
我感到欣喜若狂。我感觉，哦天哪，一切都要成了。我们要——社区正在团结起来。
And then what happened next? What changed?
然后接下来发生了什么？什么变了？
Then we started getting threatening calls, and people telling us get out or die, or leave this time, you-- awfully bad words. And we don't want you here. You're not wanted here.
然后我们开始接到威胁电话，人们叫我们滚蛋或者去死，或者说这次滚蛋，你——非常难听的话。我们不想要你在这儿。这里不欢迎你。
People threw eggs and bottles at their house. The threatening phone calls continued. Some people avoided them on the street. One day, their car windows were broken. And then on a day in December--
人们往他们家扔鸡蛋和瓶子。威胁电话持续不断。有些人甚至在街上躲着他们。有一天，他们的车窗被砸碎了。然后，在12月的一天——
We were shot at, OK? The detectives out of Jeff City said it wasn't kids, that we were shot at from the top of the school with a rifle. And it came through our bedroom wall.
我们被枪击了，好吗？杰斐逊城的侦探说那不是小孩干的，我们是从学校顶上被人用步枪射击的。子弹穿透了我们的卧室墙壁。
Jackie showed me the bullet hole, big enough to put her thumb in. The timing was so strange. Jackie and Kenny are not sure why somebody would take a shot at them at that point in their time in Canalou. Maybe, Jackie thinks, somebody saw that they were finally having some success and just couldn't stand it. In any case, the bullet was the beginning of the end.
杰基给我看了那个弹孔，大到可以把她的拇指塞进去。时机非常奇怪。杰基和肯尼不确定为什么会有人在他们留在卡纳卢的那段时间向他们开枪。杰基认为，也许有人看到他们终于取得了一些成功，就无法忍受了。无论如何，那颗子弹是结束的开始。
There's nothing. There's just nothing left. I guess we had hopes of building it back, getting some of that back it used to have. But it's impossible because them people's gone. You just can't go back. And I guess we thought we could. And now we're ready to sell out and move on.
什么都没有了。真的什么都不剩了。我想我们曾有希望重建它，找回它曾经拥有的那些东西。但这不可能，因为那些人已经离开了。你就是回不去了。我想我们曾以为我们可以。而现在我们准备卖掉房子，继续前行了。
Really?
真的吗？
Just go on down the road. I am. I'm tired of trying to build something back, I guess.
只是顺着路走下去。我是这么想的。我想我已经厌倦了尝试重建什么了。
At that point in our interview, Jackie waved to me to turn off my tape recorder, tears in her eyes. She ran out of the room to get some tissues, came back, took a minute, and then let me turn the tape recorder back on.
在采访的那一刻，杰基挥手让我关掉录音机，眼含泪水。她跑出房间拿纸巾，回来后，花了一分钟平复情绪，然后让我重新打开录音机。
That's the first time, that's the first time I've heard him, I guess, really sound defeated.
这是第一次，这是第一次我听到他，我想，听起来真的被击败了。
The two of you must have talked about, well, should we go, right?
你们两个一定讨论过，嗯，我们要不要离开，对吧？
Oh, yes. I've said, I'm through. I can't take anymore. And then I say, oh, well, maybe this project will make a difference. And we've had three pretty rough years here, where we've been-- just people don't like us here. And that's hard to accept when you're not wanted and you're just not liked. That's really hard to give in to, you know.
哦，是的。我说过，我受够了。我再也受不了了。然后我又说，哦，好吧，也许这个项目会带来改变。我们在这一直度过了三个非常艰难的年头，我们一直——就是人们不喜欢我们待在这儿。当你不仅不被欢迎，甚至被人讨厌时，这很难接受。你知道，这真的很难屈服。
Kenny had never actually said to her before this moment that he was ready to move away.
在此之前，肯尼从未对她说过他准备搬走。
You ever hear this phrase, "no good deed goes unpunished?"
你听过这句话吗，“善行必遭惩罚”？
Of what?
什么？
No good deed goes unpunished, yeah.
善行必遭惩罚，没错。
Well, probably not. But anyway, maybe we hadn't done such a good deed for these people around here. It's not what they wanted that's for sure. Maybe it's more what we wanted than what they wanted. I'd have to think about it. They get it the way they want it. They've had it this way before we come here. And it'll be this way after we leave.
嗯，可能不是。但无论如何，也许我们对这儿周围的人并没有做过什么善行。可以肯定的是，这不是他们想要的。也许是我们想要的东西多过他们想要的。我得考虑一下。他们想要按他们的方式来。在我们来之前他们就是这样。我们离开后也还会是这样。
In order to do good of any kind, you have to have a vision of the way that you want things. There is a ruthlessness to changing the world, to imposing your will on what the world is. And the danger of having a vision, of course, is that your vision can cloud your eyes about what is really there. Often when I talked to Jackie, I was struck with her vision of Canalou, with how alive the past was to her. People who stayed in town for 40 years saw a change from what it was back then to what it is now. But without the advantage of watching the daily erosion of this town, Jackie can still see it as it was. And when she talked about it, it was always a version of the past that had the quality of a fairy tale, of something barely sounding real.
为了做任何形式的善事，你必须对你想要的东西有一个愿景。改变世界、将你的意志强加于世界现状，这本身就带有残酷性。而拥有愿景的危险在于，你的愿景会遮蔽你的双眼，让你看不清现实。我与杰基交谈时，常被她对卡纳卢的愿景所触动，被过去对她来说是多么鲜活所触动。在镇上待了40年的人，看着这里从当年的模样变成如今的样子。但如果没有看着这个城镇每日被侵蚀的这种观察优势，杰基依然能看到它曾经的模样。当她谈论它时，那总是带有一种童话色彩的过去版本，听起来几乎不像是真的。
One day I was walking through an old abandoned house on the town's west side, one of the buildings that the kids called their clubhouses. The roof's broken through, the floor is torn up, walls crumbling. Jason, Rick and Lavanna's nephew, took me there in the rain.
有一天，我穿过镇西边一栋废弃的旧房子，那是孩子们称之为俱乐部会所的建筑之一。屋顶塌陷，地板被拆除，墙壁摇摇欲坠。里克和拉瓦娜的侄子杰森在雨中带我去了那里。
There's lumber everywhere, insulation from the ceiling. And then there's a rope where that chimney used to be. And they nailed the rope up here, and we'll just every once in a while climb up it. It's not really safe, but we ain't got nothing to do. Whatever we can find around here is what we do. It's not much.
到处都是木材，天花板上的隔热层。那儿有一根绳子，就是原来烟囱所在的位置。他们把绳子钉在这里，我们偶尔就会爬上去。这其实不安全，但我们没事可做。我们在周围能找到什么就玩什么。没多少东西。
The day after Jason and I stood there, I was driving by this very house with Kenny and Jackie Wharton. When Jackie looks at this house, she doesn't just see a dangerous wreck of a place that she thinks should be torn down right now in the here and now. She also sees what it was back when, the home of her school teacher, Mrs. Powell.
我和杰森站在那里的第二天，我正开车带着肯尼和杰基·沃顿经过这栋房子。当杰基看着这栋房子时，她看到的不仅仅是一个危险的烂摊子，她认为现在、此时此刻就应该把它拆掉。她看到的还有它过去的样子，是她学校老师鲍威尔太太的家。
The one thing I remember about it-- she had a lot of doilies, white, starched, crocheted doilies, like right in the middle of her coffee table. And right in the middle of that, she had a candy dish. And she would always offer you a piece of candy. And you were allowed to take it if they offered. And that was the main thing.
我关于它唯一记得的事——她有很多装饰布，白色的，上过浆的，钩编的装饰布，就像放在她咖啡桌中间那样。在正中央，她有一个糖果碟。她总是会请你吃块糖。如果他们请你，你被允许拿一颗。那是主要的事情。
And she had a glass slipper on her dresser that I used to just love to look at. Somehow when the light would come through the bedroom window, it would hit this glass slipper. And it would just shimmer. And I thought probably it was made of diamonds. Yeah, she was probably the richest lady in town and nobody knew.
她在梳妆台上有一个玻璃鞋，我以前非常喜欢看。不知怎么的，当光线穿过卧室窗户时，它会照在这个玻璃鞋上。它就会闪闪发光。我当时以为它大概是钻石做的。是啊，她大概是镇上最富有的女人，而没人知道。
It's the clarity of Jackie's vision, her vision of the town that was-- or the town that seemed to be there anyway, when she was a kid-- combined with her sheer willfulness, her effectiveness in making things happen. This is the combination that led her and her husband down the path that they've taken for these last three years. It's only now that a rifle shot provided her with a different vision of what Canalou is, a second vision of the town to replace that first one that she started with. It's only that that made her and her husband able to move away.
这正是杰基愿景的清晰度，她对那个城镇曾经的愿景——或者无论如何，她小时候看起来就是那样的城镇——结合她纯粹的执着，她在让事情发生方面的有效性。正是这种组合导致她和丈夫在过去三年里走上了他们所走的路。直到现在，一颗步枪子弹给了她对卡纳卢是什么的另一种愿景，第二个城镇的愿景，用它取代了她最初开始时的那个。正是这一点，才让她和丈夫能够搬走。
[MUSIC - "HIGHWAY 61 REVISITED" BY BOB DYLAN]
[音乐 - 鲍勃·迪伦的《重访61号公路》]
Coming up, do-gooders with $1 million a day in their pockets to spend and plane tickets overseas. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，口袋里每天有100万美元可供挥霍、有着海外机票的行善者。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different stories on that theme. Today's program, Do-Gooders, why they often fail, why they sometimes succeed. We have arrived at act two of our program.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，《行善者》，他们为何常常失败，为何有时成功。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。
Act Two. Humanitarians. In 1994, in the African country of Rwanda, the Hutu government instructed its people to go out and kill their neighbors, co-workers, friends, fellow church members who happen to be Tutsi. At least 800,000 people were murdered. And although there were several different moments when international action could have conceivably stopped or slowed the killing, the world did nothing, held back, in fact, at various points by the United States government.
第二幕。《人道主义者》。1994年，在非洲国家卢旺达，胡图族政府指示其国民去杀害他们的邻居、同事、朋友、教会成员，那些碰巧是图西族的人。至少有80万人被谋杀。尽管有几个不同的时刻，国际行动本可以设想停止或减缓杀戮，但世界什么也没做，事实上，在各个阶段都被美国政府所阻碍。
But after the biggest part of the genocide was over, the international community did finally intervene. Philip Gourevitch has written about all this in his book We Wish to Inform You That Tomorrow We Will be Killed With Our Families: Stories from Rwanda.
但在大屠杀最惨烈的部分结束后，国际社会终于进行了干预。菲利普·古雷维奇在他的书《我们希望能通知你，明天我们将被杀害：来自卢旺达的故事》中记录了这一切。
Finally, the killing was brought to a halt by a rebel army within Rwanda. And the command that had been going out over the government radio to the Hutu majority had been previously, "kill all the Tutsis, join in the killing." Now it was, "flee, join in the exodus." And really close to a million and a half or 2 million people fled Rwanda in the largest, fastest mass exodus in modern recorded history, across the borders into Tanzania, but primarily also into what was then Zaire, the Congo, under Mobutu.
最终，杀戮被卢旺达境内的叛军所阻止。此前，通过政府广播电台向胡图族多数派发出的命令一直是：“杀光所有图西人，加入杀戮。”现在变成了：“逃跑，加入大迁徙。”真的有近150万到200万人逃离了卢旺达，这是现代有记录历史中规模最大、速度最快的大规模迁徙，越过边界进入坦桑尼亚，但主要也是进入了当时扎伊尔（现在的刚果），在蒙博托统治下。
And this enormous out-rush of people was perceived broadly as an exodus from the genocide. In other words, we in the world beyond had been told, my goodness, there's a lot of killing going on inside Rwanda. And then we're told there are a lot of people fleeing. And the obvious assumption was that these people must in some way be fleeing the atrocities. In fact--
而这一巨大的人潮被广泛视为从种族灭绝中的逃亡。换句话说，我们这些外部世界的人被告知，天哪，卢旺达境内正在发生大量的杀戮。然后我们被告知有很多人正在逃离。显而易见的假设是，这些人一定是在某种程度上逃避暴行。事实上——
Right. That these people were potential victims.
没错。这些人是潜在的受害者。
In some sense that they were victims. By virtue of displacement, the image of a refugee is the image of a victim. And many of the people who were fleeing were people who were essentially civilians caught up in the turmoil and displacement of this conflict. On the other hand, a very great many of them were also people who had been active as either ordinary killers, as they're called in Rwanda, or as the organizers of the killers, the militia, the military, the civic leaders, the church leaders, the school teachers, and doctors, and so forth-- the so-called intellectuals who presided over the population when it was at home. And who essentially were leading this population into exile to create a rump genocidal state.
在某种意义上，他们是受害者。因为流离失所，难民的形象就是受害者的形象。许多逃离的人本质上是卷入这场冲突的动乱和流离失所的平民。另一方面，其中很大一部分人也是那些曾积极参与的人，或者是被称为卢旺达的“普通杀手”，或者是杀手的组织者、民兵、军方、公民领袖、教会领袖、学校老师、医生等等——那些在他们家乡时统治民众的所谓知识分子。而他们本质上是在带领这群人流亡，以建立一个残存的种族灭绝国家。
It was then that you had this incredibly large humanitarian influx into the Congo in particular-- into Zaire, particularly into the towns of Goma and Bukavu, the border towns-- as vast airlifts and an enormous outpouring of international aid went to establish massive refugee camps and essentially cater to this huge refugee outpouring.
也就是那时，出现了大规模的人道主义涌入，特别是在刚果——进入扎伊尔，特别是进入边界城镇戈马和布卡武——随着大量运输机空运，海量国际援助涌入以建立大规模难民营，基本上满足了这庞大的难民潮。
And some of the organizations that were going at that point-- I think at one point you say it was $1 million a day that was being spent.
你提到当时有些组织，我想你提到过一天有100万美元被花费。
At that point, it was much more than $1 million a day. $1 million a day was what it came to be averaged out as over a three-year period. So you can imagine that at that point, when they were bringing in transport planes around the clock, these transport planes would touch down on this runway, drop the back door, and fleets of white Land Cruisers would pour out with aid workers. They were bringing in water sanitation and vast plumbing systems. They were bringing in every known kind of sanitation engineer from all over the world.
在那一点上，远不止每天100万美元。这是三年期间平均算下来的每天100万美元。所以你可以想象在那个时候，当他们昼夜不停地带进运输机时，这些运输机降落在跑道上，放下后门，成群的白色陆地巡洋舰满载着援助人员涌出。他们带进来了水卫生设施和庞大的管道系统。他们带来了来自世界各地各种已知的环境卫生工程师。
And this is the International Red Cross, some of the groups were--
这是国际红十字会，有些组织是——
Literally there were scores, perhaps more than 100, private organizations. There were many smaller Christian organizations and church-based organizations. You had Caritas from six or seven different countries. You had World Vision. They all come in with their flags. It was a traffic jam.
实际上有数十个，可能超过100个私人组织。有许多较小的基督教组织和基于教会的组织。你有来自六七个不同国家的明爱组织。你有世界展望会。他们都带着旗帜而来。那是一场交通堵塞。
One of the things that you write is that very quickly Hutu power, which had conducted the genocide, took over the camps and established itself.
你写到的其中一件事是，胡图族势力，那些进行种族灭绝的势力，非常迅速地接管了难民营并确立了自己的统治。
Well, that's the terrible thing. What appeared to be a humanitarian disaster was, of course, really a political disaster. It was the consequences of a government that had sought to exterminate much of its people. And that government fled and presided over the camps. The same civic structures and political structures immediately replicated themselves, and there was enormous violence in the camps very quickly.
嗯，那是可怕的事。看起来是一场人道主义灾难，当然，实际上是一场政治灾难。这是一个曾试图灭绝其大部分国民的政府所带来的后果。那个政府逃亡并统治了这些营地。同样的公民结构和政治结构立即自我复制，营地里很快就出现了巨大的暴力。
These camps were set up within a mile of the Rwandan border, so they were like terrorist bases right on the border.
这些营地建立在离卢旺达边界一英里内，所以它们就像就在边界上的恐怖分子基地。
And in fact, the Hutu powers were staging raids from those bases.
事实上，胡图族势力正是在那些基地发起突袭。
Regularly. There was killing going on wherever there were camps. There was a very, very high murder rate surrounding them, basically, murder by the same militias who'd carried out the genocide. It was really quite an extraordinarily brilliant public relations move, frankly, by which the forces that had committed genocide almost immediately that they finished killing, managed to convert themselves in the public imagination into the victims of the catastrophe by becoming refugees, by exploiting our generosity with humanitarian aid, and by basically buffaloing our imaginations to the degree that we just imagined, oh, those poor people. We're giving them help. Thank goodness we're doing something.
定期进行。只要有营地的地方就有杀戮发生。在它们周围有非常非常高的谋杀率，基本上是被执行大屠杀的同一民兵所实施的谋杀。坦率地说，这是一个非常非常精彩的公关手段，那些实施了种族灭绝的力量在杀戮结束后几乎立即成功地在公众想象中将自己转化成了灾难的受害者，通过成为难民，通过利用我们对人道主义援助的慷慨，以及通过从根本上欺骗我们的想象力，以至于我们只是想象，哦，那些可怜的人。我们正在给他们帮助。感谢上帝我们在做些什么。
And the terrible thing I found, Ira, was whenever I'd go to visit these camps, I'd meet people who were more like me. Which is to say college educated, Western, nice European and American and North American men and women in their 20s who came over basically with the idea, I will do something that is simple and straightforward and good. There will be suffering. I will learn how to get clean water to these people, how to dole out food to these people, how to help them dig trenches to dispose of their waste in a way that's safe for them. I will do good, it will be unambiguous, and I will get some satisfaction from that. And I will also feel like I'm not a passive witness to the horrors of the world. And in fact, what they were doing is they were catering the horrors of the world.
而我发现的可怕的事，艾拉，是每当我去参观这些营地，我都会遇到更像我的人。也就是受过大学教育、西方、体面的欧洲和美国以及北美男人和女人，他们二十多岁，基本带着一种想法来到这里：我会做一些简单、直接且美好的事。那里会有苦难。我会学习如何为这些人提供清洁水，如何给这些人分发食物，如何帮助他们挖沟渠以安全的方式处理废物。我会做好事，这将是明确无误的，我会从中得到一些满足感。我也会觉得我不是这个世界恐怖的被动见证者。而事实上，他们所做的是他们正在为这个世界的恐怖提供服务。
There's a place on page 166 in your book. If I could ask you to read.
你的书第166页有一个地方。如果我能请你朗读一下。
"In this regime, the humanitarians were treated rather like the service staff at a seedy, mafia-occupied hotel. They were there to provide food, medicine, housewares, an aura of respectability. If at times they were pandered to, it was only because they were being set up to be cheated. If they needed to be brow-beaten, a mob quickly surrounded them. And if they were essentially the dupes of their criminal guests, there were not unwitting about it. And with time, their service effectively made them accessories to the Hutu power syndicate."
“在这种体制下，人道主义者被对待得就像一家被黑手党占领的肮脏旅馆的服务人员。他们在那儿提供食物、药品、家庭用品、一种受人尊敬的氛围。如果有时他们被迎合，那只是因为他们正被设局欺骗。如果他们需要被威吓，暴民会迅速包围他们。如果他们本质上是他们罪犯客人的傀儡，他们并不是对此一无所知。随着时间推移，他们的服务实际上使他们成为了胡图族力量集团的帮凶。”
And essentially they were keeping the whole thing going by providing the food and the blankets and all that for the Hutu powers.
本质上，他们通过提供食物和毯子等等，让整件事维持运转，支持着胡图族力量。
Through that entire period, it was this really self-evident thing that as long as those camps existed, there was an effort by the militias in the camps, by the Hutu power militias in the camps from Rwanda to start to ethnically cleanse regions around the camps. In case one day those camps were closed, they could create a rear base. So they started massacring people in the mountains. They started massacring the people in their host countries. It created tremendous turmoil.
在那整个时期，这是一件非常显而易见的事情，只要那些营地存在，胡图族民兵就在试图通过这些营地，通过在卢旺达营地的胡图族力量民兵，去对营地周围的地区进行种族清洗。万一有一天这些营地关闭了，他们可以建立一个后方基地。所以他们开始在山区屠杀平民。他们开始在东道国屠杀平民。这制造了巨大的动荡。
And there was a complete unwillingness to confront this. And sometimes they would say, well, you know, like a doctor who takes an oath to treat somebody whether he's a murderer or a good man, we, too, operate on the principle that one should give aid to people and leave the political questions to political people. But there's a very big difference between neutrality and ignorance. And it's one thing to say, well, I'm going to feed this guy even if somebody else tells me he's a criminal because my job is simply to feed people. But it's another to say, I don't want to know he's a murderer because that, in some way, taints my experience here. And I found that that was quite often what I heard. And that was very disturbing.
人们完全不愿意面对这一点。有时他们会说，嗯，你知道，就像一个宣誓无论患者是杀人犯还是好人都要救治的医生，我们也秉持这样的原则：应该给人们提供援助，把政治问题留给政治人物。但中立和无知之间有很大的区别。说“我将喂饱这个人，即使其他人告诉我他是罪犯，因为我的工作仅仅是喂饱人们”，这是一回事；但说“我不希望知道他是杀人犯，因为那在某种程度上玷污了我的经历”，则是另一回事。我发现我经常听到那种说法。那非常令人不安。
Now, in your book, you also talk about ordinary Rwandans who try to help out and save people in ways that they can. And one of the people who you talk about is the manager of a hotel named-- I'm not sure I can pronounce his last name-- Paul Rusesabagina?
现在，在你的书中，你还谈到了普通卢旺达人，他们以自己力所能及的方式尝试帮助和拯救人们。你谈到的人之一是一位酒店经理，名叫——我不确定我能不能读出他的姓——保罗·鲁萨巴吉纳？
Yeah. In Kigali, there's one basically world-class hotel, sort of the best hotel in town, the Hotel des Mille Collines. And it turned out that Paul, who had been put in charge of the hotel, had used all of his considerable human resources, as well as his liquor cabinet, and all of his connections to the ruling, military, and political elite, to continuously buy the security of his guests for as long as he could, until eventually they were saved by a prisoner exchange.
是的。在基加利，有一家基本上是世界级的酒店，算是镇上最好的酒店，千丘酒店。事实证明，负责这家酒店的保罗，利用了他所有可观的人力资源，以及他的酒柜，还有他与统治阶级、军事和政治精英的所有联系，去持续地购买客人的安全，直到最终他们通过囚犯交换获救。
The way you describe him, he comes off like Humphrey Bogart in Casablanca.
你对他的描述，他看起来很像《卡萨布兰卡》里的汉弗莱·鲍嘉。
He was a very reserved man.
他是一个非常内敛的人。
But one of the things he tells you is that one of his main weapons is that he always had alcohol. No matter how long into the crisis it was, he saw that they had alcohol in the hotel. And everybody wanted it, and he would serve the Hutu leaders, and apparently he would bribe people when he needed to.
但其中一件事他告诉你的是，他主要的武器之一是他一直有酒精。不管危机持续了多久，他都确保酒店里有酒精。每个人都想要，他会提供给胡图族领导人，显然当他需要时，他会贿赂别人。
Oh, yeah. He described how he would give out these gifts of alcohol to people who would come by. And in that way, they would be almost like it was the goose with the golden egg. You didn't want to kill him because then the supply would dry up. He had set up a whole elaborate commerce. And so the leaders would come to the hotel and he'd give them a little bit to drink. And his condition was you leave my hotel alone.
哦，是的。他描述了他如何向来访的人发放酒精礼物。那样的话，他们几乎就像是那只下金蛋的鹅。你不想杀他，因为那样供应就会断绝。他建立了一整套精密的商业体系。所以领导人会来到酒店，他会给他们一点酒喝。他的条件是：别碰我的酒店。
And he'd negotiate for the things he wanted. He also used alcohol to buy food so that his people wouldn't starve. The water had been cut to the hotel, and the guests were forced to drink the swimming pool. But he managed to keep them going.
他会为他想要的东西讨价还价。他也用酒精购买食物，这样他的人民就不会挨饿。酒店的供水被切断了，客人们被迫喝游泳池的水。但他成功地让他们坚持了下去。
You describe a number of times when the phone rings. I'll take one in particular. A phone rings and wakes him up. And a lieutenant says to him, have everyone out of the hotel in 30 minutes. They're being rounded up.
你描述了很多次电话响的情景。我特别举一个例子。电话响了，把他吵醒。一位中尉对他说，30分钟内让酒店里的所有人滚蛋。他们正在被围捕。
Yeah. This was about 6:30 in the morning one day. And he's being told to relinquish all of the guests in his hotel. In many ways, his principle was that of a man who believed in the ethic of hospitality. They're my guests, I must protect them. He told this lieutenant, look, give me half an hour to get up, get washed, and I'll deal with you then.
是的。那大概是有一天早上6点半。他被告知要交出酒店里的所有客人。在许多方面，他的原则是一位相信待客之道的男人的原则。他们是我的客人，我必须保护他们。他告诉这位中尉，看，给我半小时起床、洗漱，到时候我会处理你的事。
And in that half hour, one thing that he had that was one of his weapons was a phone line. And he used it to call all over the world. And he immediately called to Europe, he called to the French foreign ministry. Now, France was the primary political patron of the genocidal regime at that time. He called there and he spoke to people there. He called Belgium. Within about 25 minutes, one of the top commanders of the military-- in other words, this lieutenant's superior-- and also somebody from the UN, showed up at the hotel. And they came and they assured him that his guests would be OK. No foreign lives were risked. This wasn't a massive military intervention, but lives were saved.
在那半小时里，他拥有的武器之一就是一条电话线。他用它给全世界打电话。他立即给欧洲打电话，他给法国外交部打电话。现在，法国当时是种族灭绝政权的主要政治赞助者。他打过去并与那里的人说话。他给比利时打电话。在25分钟内，军方最高指挥官之一——换句话说，这位中尉的上级——还有联合国的人，出现在了酒店。他们来了，并向他保证他的客人会没事的。没有外国人的生命受到威胁。这并不是大规模军事干预，但生命得到了拯救。
A lot of times, the kind of measures it took were just the smallest human response. There's this story that you write about where this hotel manager, Paul, in the middle of May in sort of the worst of days, he is out running errands, I think trying to get alcohol for the hotel. And he comes back to the hotel. And he sees that the Interahamwe have broken in, the thugs have broken in. And they're looking for his family, they're going through his own personal apartment. And explain how he deters them. What happens?
很多时候，它所采取的措施仅仅是最细微的人类回应。你写过这样一个故事，在5月中旬最糟糕的几天里，这位酒店经理保罗正出去办杂事，我想是在试着为酒店弄酒精。他回到酒店。他看到“因特拉汉姆韦”（Interahamwe）民兵闯了进来，暴徒们闯了进来。他们在寻找他的家人，在搜查他个人的公寓。解释一下他是如何阻止他们的。发生了什么？
Well, he realized that these were some pretty uneducated militiamen. And he ran into some of them on the stairs. And he was dressed in a t-shirt and jeans or something. And he realized that they must assume that a manager would be a man in a necktie or a suit. So when they said, have you seen the manager, he said, oh, yeah, the manager. He just went that-a-way. And it was really almost like a classic Hollywood gag. He said he just went upstairs as he ran downstairs. And as he's running downstairs, he runs into another group. And he tells them the manager must have gone the other way. So he sends them all off spiraling in different directions.
嗯，他意识到这些人是一些受教育程度很低的民兵。他在楼梯上撞见了他们中的一些。他穿着一件T恤和牛仔裤之类的。他意识到他们一定认为经理会是一个打领带或穿西装的男人。所以当他们说，“你看见经理了吗？”，他说，哦，是的，经理。他刚往那边去了。这真的几乎就像一个经典的好莱坞桥段。他说他刚跑上楼，就像他跑下楼那样。当他跑下楼时，他撞见了另一群人。他告诉他们经理一定是往另一个方向跑了。所以他把他们全都支开，让他们向不同的方向散去。
And that's what saves their lives.
而这就是拯救他们生命的原因。
Yeah, the most basic, immediate wits. But I think the key to Paul, in some ways, was his instinct that everything is negotiable. And it struck me how in some very basic way, he had simply refused to relinquish free will and relinquish judgment, which I think is the part that ties him to these other humanitarians who think that in the name of neutrality and humanitarianism they have to relinquish judgment. He thought that it was because of judgment that he could be a decent man.
是的，最基本、最直接的机智。但我认为保罗的关键，在某种程度上，是他对一切都是可谈判的直觉。令我震惊的是，在某种非常基本的层面上，他仅仅拒绝放弃自由意志和判断力，我认为这正是将他与其他人道主义者联系起来的地方，这些人认为以中立和人道主义的名义，他们必须放弃判断力。他认为正是因为有了判断力，他才能成为一个体面的人。
It's interesting that the people who tend to come through well in the book are the people like Paul who are pragmatists, they're not idealists.
有趣的是，书里那些看起来表现得很好的人，都是像保罗这样的人，他们是实用主义者，不是理想主义者。
Many of the do-gooders I met, or many of the people I felt who, in one way of another, conducted themselves well in these extraordinary times of extremity, were both pragmatic and shockable. They still remained sort of indignant at wrongdoing. They were not deeply cynical. And they thought that making distinctions really mattered. They were people who simply insisted on going on as if the world were upright and normal. And in that way, they helped to make sure that it would be.
我遇到过的许多行善者，或者我感觉在这些极端时期以某种方式表现良好的人，既是务实又是容易感到震惊的。他们仍然保持着对错误行为的某种愤慨。他们并不极其愤世嫉俗。他们认为做出区分确实很重要。他们只是坚持以世界是正直和正常的方式继续生活下去。通过那种方式，他们帮助确保了世界确实会变成那样。
As you watch the United States mobilize itself in its bombings of Kosovo, what are you thinking as you see that, given the US inaction during the genocide in Rwanda?
当你看着美国动员起来对科索沃进行轰炸时，当你看到这一幕，考虑到美国在卢旺达种族灭绝期间的不作为，你在想什么？
I think that sadly, the situation in Kosovo reflects the kind of institutionalization and bastardization of the concept of humanitarian action that we saw in a very different form in the response to the refugee camps after the Rwandan genocide. We're claiming that we're bombing Yugoslavia as a humanitarian action. But it's not. It's a war. We're fighting against an army. We're trying to destroy an army.
我想悲哀的是，科索沃局势反映了我们在响应卢旺达种族灭绝后的难民营时，以一种非常不同的形式看到的那种人道主义行动概念的制度化和堕落。我们声称我们轰炸南斯拉夫是一种人道主义行动。但事实并非如此。这是一场战争。我们正在与一支军队作战。我们正在试图摧毁一支军队。
If our first objective was really, as we claim in the first week of this war, to protect the people of Kosovo, it's clear that we've actually put them in greater jeopardy at first, that their protection isn't the issue. And the language of humanitarianism has increasingly become a masquerade for a variety of different forms of action or inaction in the international community to disguise political conflicts, as if our only concern were for the loss of human life. And in that way, we end up with a series of muddled discourses and muddled motives that make it sound like if we're doing it, it must be good and often make it very hard for us to keep track of what, in fact, we are doing. The other thing that one just has to look at is how completely calculating those who conduct wars these days are.
如果我们真正的第一个目标，正如我们在这场战争的第一周所声称的那样，是保护科索沃人民，很明显我们实际上最初把他们置于了更大的危险之中，他们的保护并不是重点。人道主义的语言日益成为国际社会掩盖政治冲突、各种行动或不作为的假面具，就好像我们唯一的关心是人类生命的损失。通过这种方式，我们最终得到了一系列混乱的言论和混乱的动机，这听起来好像我们正在做的事就一定是好事，并且往往使我们很难追踪我们实际上在做什么。另一件事人们必须看到的是，那些发动战争的人现在是多么精于算计。
Well, this is the thing I was just going to say, is one of the things that comes through in the book is that the Hutu militia in the camps were very canny about exploiting Western attitudes towards them.
嗯，这就是我刚想说的，书里体现出来的一点是，营地里的胡图族民兵对于利用西方对他们的态度非常精明。
Absolutely. If I were right now trying to run a good insurrection somewhere in the world, the first thing I would do is I would appoint a commander or a minister or a general in charge of humanitarian manipulation. Look at how it was used in the Yugoslav conflict during the Bosnia War. You repeatedly saw safe havens being created, generals using them to corral people, and then going in and slaughtering them knowing that the UN wouldn't defend them.
绝对如此。如果我现在试图在世界上的某个地方发动一场成功的叛乱，我做的第一件事就是任命一位负责人道主义操纵的指挥官、部长或将军。看看在波斯尼亚战争期间的南斯拉夫冲突中它是如何被利用的。你反复看到安全区被建立，将军们利用它们来圈禁民众，然后进去屠杀他们，知道联合国不会保卫他们。
And then in many ways, I think this isn't always the humanitarians' fault. I think that the political decision-makers, the policymakers and leaders who conduct our foreign policy often use humanitarian aid to hide behind. They use it as a screen to mask their own indecision and their own unwillingness to act. And it's essentially a way of making the gestures of concern without really seeking to resolve in any meaningful way the catastrophe.
然后在许多方面，我认为这并不总是人道主义者的错。我认为那些开展我们外交政策的政治决策者、政策制定者和领导人往往利用人道主义援助作为掩护。他们把它当作屏幕，来掩盖他们自己的优柔寡断和不作为的意愿。本质上，这是一种做出关怀姿态而不真正寻求以任何有意义的方式解决灾难的方法。
Philip Gourevitch. His great, great book is called We Wish to Inform You That Tomorrow We Will Be Killed With our Families: Stories from Rwanda. We spoke on the second day of the NATO bombing of Kosovo.
菲利普·古雷维奇。他那部了不起、非常了不起的书叫《我们希望能通知你，明天我们将被杀害：来自卢旺达的故事》。我们是在北约轰炸科索沃的第二天进行交谈的。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, Sylvia Lemus, and Mickey Greenberg. Our story about Canalou was produced by Julie Snyder with help from Mary Wiltenburg.
嗯，我们今天的节目是由南希·厄普代克和我自己，以及艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德制作的。特约编辑保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作协助来自豪尔赫·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼、西尔维娅·莱姆斯和米奇·格林伯格。关于卡纳卢的故事由朱莉·斯奈德制作，玛丽·威尔滕堡协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you know, you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website www.thisamericanlife.org. During the week that we were producing this episode of our program, a cartoonist named Jessica Abel sat with us documenting the process. She made a comic book about that. You can get it on the website, again www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买这期或我们任何节目的录音带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。或者你知道，你可以在我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org免费收听我们的大部分节目。在我们制作这集节目的那周，一位名叫杰西卡·阿贝尔的漫画家和我们坐在一起记录了这个过程。她为此制作了一本漫画书。你可以在网站上获取它，再次说明是www.thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia who says that if you have any complaints about our Chicago-based radio program, just remember--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他说，如果你对我们这个基于芝加哥的广播节目有任何投诉，请记住——
See, we're not Sikeston. We ain't never been, we'll never be.
看，我们不是塞克斯顿。我们从来都不是，也永远不会是。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。